hello world Shawn grooms here again with
freako camp and in this video I'll be
explaining what sets are a set is a
collection of distinct objects called
elements or members an element is
essentially anything you want it to be
and for example elements could be
numbers letters variables more sets or
nothing at all sets are usually denoted
by capital letters such as capital a
capital B C E or F and we say that the
set contains elements for example we
could say that the set a equals the set
containing the element 5 or we can say
that 5 is an element of a now I will be
introducing a lot of symbols like this
this just means is an element of and
it'll save us a lot of time in future
videos and I don't have to write out is
an element of each time so that will
come in handy so what does a set
actually look like well there are two
common types of notation for sets and
the one I'm introducing in this video is
roster notation and it looks like this
is just curly braces with elements
inside separated by commas which is very
similar to JavaScript the only
difference being that in math we use
curly braces and in JavaScript we use a
square Brady bracket so now let's just
walk through these so the set a equals
the set containing the Elven 5 that's
how you would read this the set B equals
the set containing elements 2 3 & 4 the
set c equals the set containing elements
D F and G now D F and G they're not they
don't have to be variables there they're
either variables or they can be
characters it just depends on the
context the set E it contains no
elements in this case which has an
impact that you'll see in future videos
and finally the set F equals the set
containing elements a B and C in this
case our elements are sets so we would
read this as F equals the set containing
the set containing the element 5 the set
containing elements 2 3 & 4
and the set containing D F and G so in
the next video I'll be going over a
different form of set notation in
addition to introducing you to some
common sets and this will set us up
eventually my goal is to bring us up to
being able to define and understand
algorithms and this is where we have to
begin